hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the world rapid
Championship featuring 8-year-old
Grandmaster Roman shv who defeated not
one not two not three or four but five
grand Masters throughout the world rapid
and Blitz championship and being 8 years
old that is absolutely incredible it'd
be incredible if he only defeated one of
them but he actually defeated five of
them and um it's not official as I don't
know if um I've read in the article that
chess.com might have some somewhere in
the database that some 8-year-old
defeated a grandmas in a rapid game in
an official rapid game but um as they
well the search wasn't really conclusive
we could also say that this is the first
time an 8-year-old ever defeated a
Grandmaster uh in in in a serious
official game uh so uh his opponent for
and this is round one of the rapid event
he started off with a with a very nice
win against a very strong Jong vako of
usbekistan uh Grandmaster who also was a
part of the team that won first place in
the chess Olympiad and um yeah I mean
for those of you you probably have heard
of him of as he's a very strong player
but for those of you who haven't he also
defeated some very very strong players
in this event he defeated Anish giri he
defeated GES he defeated Jordan van
Forest he defeated uh well many Grand
Masters and Drew some very strong ones
so that being said let's check it out
and see how 8-year-old Roman shv faces
off against such a such a deadly
opponent so jonger has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to C4 we have
Pawn to C6 cing the English with the
caroan we have Pawn to D4 and D5
transposing into the slav defense C
captures C captures and now Bishop to F4
uh The Exchange variation of the slav uh
Knight to F6 and now Pawn to E3 we have
Knight to C6 and Bishop to D3 so sort of
a London system setup uh Bishop to G 4
and now Pawn to F3 kicking away the
bishop Bishop back to D7 and now Knight
to C3 so uh very nicely developing
pieces we have Pawn to E6 and pawn to G4
still all Theory G4 is considered to be
by far the strongest move here Bishop to
E7 and Knight G to E2 the Knight can
later on come to F4 if the bishop moves
or you can put the Knight to G3 where
you control a lot of squares uh castles
and now there are a couple of games
where A3 was played also H4 is a known
move but here we have King to F2 and it
is now as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game in a fairly equal uh
position white white is probably a
little bit better but nothing
spectacular so Knight to E8 uh Roman
prepares to advance the pawn all the way
to F5 but he also wants to REM maneuver
the Knight to
D6 uh we have Pawn to H4 and now Knight
to D6 and here is a very very
interesting moment in the game where you
really want to uh continue advancing
those pawns but the problem is if black
gets Knight to B4 in it it could be very
annoying and uh if you allow Knight B4
then the bishop comes to B1 with your
Rook undeveloped on A1 and if you
develop The Rook then still Knight to B4
attacks the bishop and if the bishop
moves back then Knight to C4 is just
very annoying and okay uh you have to
defend the B Pawn let's say you play
something like B3 Knight A3 and again
you you're not going to be able to keep
your light squore Bishop which is kind
of the key piece in the attack for uh
for white here so instead Pawn to A3
that's why the uh the you know the
attack slows down a little bit we have
Pawn to F5 and now Pawn to G5 and Rook
to C8 nicely continuing development
putting pressure on White's Queen side
and now uh of course uh Roman's plan is
to put the Knight on A5 to control C4
and B3 and this should be countered with
B4 as most most positions should however
Queen to C2 was played and now Knight to
A5 as B4 was not played so Pawn to B3
stopping Knight C4 uh and now Bishop
back to E8 Shifting the bishop over to
this diagonal uh even though uh you
could continue with something like Queen
B6 to put pressure on the pawn here and
also Knight to E4 is a nice idea since
the Knight if captured then the bishop
gets attacked and the bishop also does
not have any squares H but okay Bishop
to E8 was played also a nice move uh
Queen to B2 unpinning from the from the
Rook on the C file and now Pawn to B5 we
have Rook a to C1 and pawn to A6 now
solidifying on the on the queen side and
now Bishop to G3 here Bishop to H2 is
much stronger and is the move that white
should play but after Bishop to G3 this
just runs into Knight the E4 check still
nothing um you know decisive but uh you
you shouldn't give up such a strong
piece so Knight the E4 check was played
uh and again if if you
capture uh with the pawn then of course
F captures on e4 delivers a check from
the rook and again the bishop will be
lost so he decided to give up the bishop
right away we have F captures and now
Knight to F4 going after the E6 Pawn so
defending it Bishop to D7 and now comes
F captures on e4 uh definitely best you
don't have to worry about the pin here
there's no way to actually Advance any
pawns to attack that Knight D captures
on e4 and now King to G2 you cannot go
after the E4 Pawn if if you grab it
right away then you run into some Bishop
to C6 uh action and after King F3 sort
of to defend it then Queen D5 comes as
the Knight here is spin so you can even
play that and if you defend it then even
Knight captures on B3 threatening Knight
to D2 with a royal Fork as this Knight
now is also pinned so this is a recipe
for disaster so instead a nice King to
G2 and now Pawn to E5 Pawn to E5 is a
good idea but you should first prepare
it with um Knight B7 Knight to D6 as uh
uh it doesn't seem like white has an
active plan here you should take all the
time you need to put your pieces on
optimal squares before deciding um for
such a pawn push but okay it's a rapid
game Pawn to E5 D captures on E5 and now
Bishop to G4 going after Bishop to F3
check but he missed Knight C to D5 and
this is now somewhat annoying for black
uh because if you go for this bishop to
F3 check let a king H2 and Bishop
captures on H1 there's Rook captures on
C8 and now if you capture Knight
captures on E7 check with the Royal Fork
will uh cost you the queen and if you
don't uh well then you're you're just
worse there's not much uh that can be
done here for example Queen to D7 just
Pawn to E6 can be played and uh not a
lot of not a lot of good squares for
that Queen what do you play Queen to B7
then comes Knight to H5 uh and all of a
sudden you're getting checkmated so uh
all sorts of tricky stuff in the
position here so Queen to D7 was played
and now comes King to H2 and this is a a
Miss um in a very very complicated
position uh sorry about that as it is a
rapid game
uh but here you should go for Rook
captures on C8 Queen captures and C8 or
you go for Rook captures on C8 doesn't
really matter and then Knight to B6 but
this is probably uh why he why he
decided to avoid it because of the
bishop captures an A3 move and now it
looks like if Queen captures you have
this queen to D2 check and if you don't
capture the queen what else do you play
well Queen to A2 this is the move you
have to find and then after the queen
moves doesn't really matter you will
play Queen cap Knight captures here and
after Bishop to F3 check just King H2
and it doesn't matter uh White is just
uh completely winning black has no no
counterplay here whatsoever of course
you could capture the Knight but then
Queen captures on A3 and if you capture
here uh Queen can capture on A5 and
you're you're at least up a piece so
that's the problem uh but King to H2 was
played allowing black sort of a way back
into the game Bishop to F3 and now Pawn
to E6 a very strong move but again Rook
captur on C8 was more precise Queen to
B7 now guarding the B6 Square which is
um very good for black Rook captur on C8
we have Rook captur on C8 and now Rook
to C1 offering a trade of Rooks and now
Rook captures Queen captures and Bishop
to D6 still white is completely winning
and Roman is barely holding on here but
this is rapid the position is extremely
complicated and remember when I say that
someone is completely winning here that
means with precise engine play and when
you have you know a little time on the
clock that's not what happens when
humans are playing so Queen to D2 and
now Knight to C6 imagine what you would
get if you put uh Tal's positions uh on
an engine they would you know the engine
would say t tal is a Madman but you know
try playing it against tal not happening
so here Knight to F6 check trading the
Knight to mess up the black King's Pawn
structure and also to pick up the bishop
on D6 G captures on F6 and now Queen
captures on D6 we have F captur on G5 uh
and now the move you have to play to win
is either h captur on G G5 or just Queen
D5 just prepare this E7 push uh and
there's not much you can do here for
example if you capture E7 check covers
uh f8 and uh F7 and E8 Queen will be
will be game over but in the game Knight
to D5 was played which works uh pretty
much against every move that black makes
except one and that is Queen to G7 white
is still winning or maybe even close to
winning but you have to play it very
precisely the only way to win is H cap
on G5 but you don't find this in a in a
Speed game for example Capt captur how
do you stop Queen H5 check followed by
Queen to H1 you have to play King to G1
and now after Queen H6 going for Queen
to H1 you have to play King to F2 uh
yeah good good luck finding that and now
whatever you play there's just nothing
and even if you don't go for that if you
go for Queen captures on C6 there's
Queen to B2 check followed by Queen to
G2 Checkmate wherever the white king
goes uh so instead after Queen to G s
Bishop to F2 was played but now all of a
sudden Roman is winning and he wins the
game G captures on H4 how do you stop
Checkmate well you have to defend Knight
to F4 is played now comes Queen to B2
threatening Queen captures on F2 we have
Knight to H3 defending the bishop and he
goes back Queen to G7 again threatens
mate Knight to F4 and now Queen to B2
Knight to H3 and queen to G7 and Knight
to F4 and now if he plays the queen back
to B2 one more time it will be a draw by
three-fold repetition so he has to
figure out something else uh what is
this else feel free to pause the video
and win the game for Roman shv while I
give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
all of the nice tactics here and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course Queen to A1 and now
that the Knight blocks uh uh checkmate
with Knight to G2 the next move is Queen
to F1 going after Queen captures on G2
Checkmate so Knight captures on H4 now
guarding G2 but also if uh Queen to H1
check you can sort of start running with
King to G3 but uh in order to stop
Checkmate you had to give up the bishop
so Queen captures on F2 check King H3
Queen F1 check King to H2 king queen to
H1 check King to G3 uh and now uh of
course Queen to G1 with check uh setting
up for a very nice Checkmate King to H3
and now Bishop to G4 uh with a most
spectacular Checkmate uh so yeah this is
the first game Roman shv played in the
world rapid Championship he defeated a
very very strong grandmas and he played
a very very strong event throughout the
world rapid and Bliss Championship he
defeated vako Christiansen shevchenko
Alan pish and Anand not the the big
Anand the the small Anand but still you
know Anand is an Anand and yeah
incredible event um I mean if an
8-year-old defeats a grandm everywhere
it hits the headlines but if he beats
five grand Masters that's uh well that's
something else and he even met Magnus
after the rapid event uh got to meet him
uh you know probably Magnus signed
something for him and Magnus said that
he's very impressed and that he wouldn't
be surprised if we see him in top uh top
events you know maybe in a maybe even in
a in a few years of course he will have
to gain some rating before he is invited
to Elite events but you know if you if
you play like this at eight um um I mean
should be should be fairly quick before
that happens and it's sort of a uh you
know the the opposite of ala story you
know also uh Christiansen when he lost
to him he's the second Grandmaster that
he defeated said for the Norwegian
television uh that he never heard of him
H but probably he should have heard of
him as you know if he can he can defeat
him and that it's incredible to be
playing uh such strong chesses at the
age of eight as he himself only
basically learned how the pieces move at
the age of eight and then you have um
alza who hasn't even started learning
the rules until he was like nine so you
know uh you hear stories when they they
start at like the age of three maybe
even two and a half U and but sometimes
you have the Ala story who started very
very very late uh but uh you know for
some reason it it worked well for him uh
but yeah uh that's the the game hope you
guys enjoyed it and a little bit of
information about the the incredible
Roman shv very much looking forward to
seeing what he does next I would like to
uh thank Welsh fan wangan Sasha vidler
Mark Henley Brennan and Michael mels for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it uh and as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World and sorry in the previous video I
said it was 2023 when
2024 uh yeah I'm pretty sure that will
happen throughout January as it does
every year uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your
day